Cuenta atrás para el último despegue del
arian 5 al espacio el legendario cohete
europeo dejó la tierra por última vez el
miércoles en una misión en la que
transportó dos satélites uno de ellos
para el ejército francés fue sobre todo
una misión simbólica los habitantes de
curu en la guayana francesa se reunieron
para despedirlo los sucesivos
lanzamientos desde el territorio de
ultramar francés fueron parte de sus
vidas durante 27 años sin embargo el
proyecto tuvo un comienzo accidentado
durante el primer lanzamiento en 1996 un
error informático provocó la explosión
del cohete a sólo 40 segundos de vuelo
superamos este fallo volvimos al aire
convertimos este lanzador en un éxito
increíble tanto Industrial como
comercialmente una fiabilidad
absolutamente fenomenal una tasa de
éxito del 98% es como un reloj suizo
en pocos años harían cinco se convirtió
en el cohete de referencia para el
lanzamiento de satélites comerciales
permitiendo a Europa hacer una gran
potencia espacial pero la creciente
competencia de empresas privadas como
spacex cambió el panorama por lo que el
harían cinco ya no estaba a la altura de
sus contemporáneos y para seguir el
ritmo del mercado está previsto que se
ha sustituido por el arian 6 pero al
igual que su hermano mayor el cohete
tiene problemas para su Debut
el proyecto Lleva años de retraso y no
despegará antes de 2024 privando a
Europa del acceso al espacio por primera
vez en 40 años
[Música]